a bill making its way through the state
legislature is working to change how
teachers are evaluated but Clark County
schools are against it saying this will
impact student achievement 8 news now
education reporter Joshua peguero looks
into what the bill could do
students are days away from summer break
but by the time they return to class in
August there will be some changes one
thing the Clark County School District
doesn't want to see is a change to
teacher performance evaluations
ab269 seeks to do that evaluating an
employee shouldn't happen just on a
one-time basis I think when we look at
the constant feedback that we give all
employees should be ongoing under the
proposed Bill if a teacher receives two
consecutive evaluations of effective or
highly effective they could choose not
to participate the following year in the
letter of opposition CCSD says the
current evaluations need to be better at
aligning with student expectations
District data shows only one in five
middle school students are proficient in
math this last couple years this board
has allocated extra resources for for
Teacher raises for employee compensation
so all of that encompasses really a
clear focus on instruction the Clark
County teachers union doesn't have a
position on this bill yet they question
the district's leadership we believe
that educators are don't aren't afraid
of accountability and so you know our
concern is more of whether the
superintendent is the right leadership
for CCSD Nevada lawmakers are seeking to
invest in additional 2.3 billion dollars
into State schools they have concerns
about his track record when it comes to
student outcomes and and it's he the
Right leader to effectively spend the
historically amount the historic
investment that lawmakers are making in
education a survey recently ranked
Nevada 49th in the country for student
performance Joshua peguero eight news
now
ab-269 passed in the assembly and is
currently in the Senate awaiting a vote
a date has yet to be set for it